Hey everybody, This is Brent Dixon. I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 192 in St Cloud, Florida.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is very happily sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old scout master.
This report just in from Bill McFarland, who's a long-time listener and a scout master with Troop 8 in Pittsfield, Massachusetts.
On a recent camping trip, Bill had a bout of insomnia. He stayed up most of the night wondering where the sun had gone and then it dawned on him.
Hey, this is podcast number 313..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green in the mailbag this week,
Heard from Dave Jenkins who said:
I just discovered your site and love the podcast.
Well thanks, Dave. As a new scout master, so many of the topics clearly speak to issues I've already encountered and struggled with in our own Troop.
Thank you for doing this. I plan to become a backer to see it continues forward.
Thanks for all you're doing to help scouts and scouters.
Thank you, Dave, for getting in touch.
Yeah, none of this is really brain surgery.
Most of the things that anybody encounters as a scout master have already happened thousands, if not millions, of times
And, yeah, it just takes a little experience to help you figure it out.
I'm not any smarter than anybody. I've just been around longer, right?
That's my typical excuse. but anyway,
Over on Amazon, my book, The Scouting Journey,
If you haven't read it. The Scouting Journey is my attempt at taking the ideas from Baden Powell's is to scout master ship and kind of updating them into the 21st century,
Because those ideas are the foundation of the worldwide scouting
And then they definitely translate into the myriad of cultural and social conditions and a century's worth of history.
They work.
What I wanted to do was to renew their relevance to us a century later.
But anyway, Parker Levinson left me a five-star review for the book and said that The Scouting Journey was both relevant and interesting,
And I appreciate that. Parker,
Thanks so much.
Every week we have a couple of live chat sessions.
Now these are usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
They happen at scoutmasterscgcom.
If you follow our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed, I'll announce when I'm online and ready to chat
And you can come and join the many, many people who check in every week.
We have lots of frequent flyers who come back from week to week, as well as, this past week, Dan Budd,
who's a new scout master of Troop 42 in Red Hook, New York,
And Dan stopped in to say he'd been a new scout master for just a couple of months.
It was also Dan's birthday,
So belated happy birthday to you, Dan.
Stop in at scoutmastercgcom,
Mostly Tuesday mornings and Wednesday mornings,
Watch the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed and say hello at the live chat.
I do have a favor to ask of you. if you're a regular reader or listener,
Would you please consider helping me keep the Scout Master blog and the Scout Master podcast up and running,
If the resources that I've created have helped you, here's how you can return the favor.
Two very simple ways of doing this.
Go to scoutmastercgcom.
Look at the very top of the page, over on the right hand side,
And you'll see a link that says support,
And you'll also see a link that says Patreon- P-A-T-R-E-O-N.
Through the support link, you can become a backer of scoutmastercgcom,
which is a one-time kind of subscription payment, I guess you could say,
And I have some premiums to offer you in the way of autographed copies of my books and such.
You can also make a monthly subscription payment of $5 or more through Patreon,
And that's P-A-T-R-E-O-N.
If you go to patreoncom, search for Scout Master CG,
You'll see how that all works, and there are premiums available there too.
And I want to make sure to personally thank John Romer, who became a backer since last week's podcast.
Go to scoutmastercgcom, become a backer or a patron.
I'll make sure to thank you personally on our next podcast.
Well, in this week's podcast I'm really happy to have an old friend of the podcast and the blog back, Walter Underwood,
And Walter and I have collaborated a number of times on the podcast in the past.
And a little while back I got an email from Walter asking if I had looked at the first volume of the new troop leader guidebook.
You know I hadn't, and more about why I hadn't in a second.
It's been out for a while now, but Walter was pretty excited about it.
So I made sure to get myself a copy and I looked at it.
I was pretty excited about it.
I said, Walter, let's get together and I'll record it for the podcast and everybody can share our excitement over the book.
The reason I didn't get a copy of it for a while is because of one thing that I'm kind of grumpy about,
And I apologize for being grumpy, but I but just fielding comments about this book in particular and BSA publications in general,
It's not available electronically, which is really kind of frustrating.
Now I know that you have to recap the publishing costs of the book.
I mean, it's tremendous amount of resources go into publishing something like this
And I understand that. but I would say that my books that I self publish and offer to people sell approximately two to one in electronic versions over print versions.
And while I haven't really done a formal analysis of the profits involved and everything you know, it's not a life changing amount of money, to tell you the truth.
But while I haven't really looked at that, I know that I've probably profited more from the electronic versions because they basically come to me at very little cost
in comparison to distributing print versions. to my mind-
And I could be absolutely wrong and not understand everything that's going on-
But to my mind everything that the BSA offers ought to be available in electronic version that's easily portable, that I can share with people,
And I'd be glad to pay the full price of a print version for it.
And this troop leader guidebook, which is the first of a two volume set- and the second volume is supposed to come out sometime soon-
I'd be happy to pay the full print price for an electronic version of it.
So I'll get off my soapbox and I'll stop being grumpy.
I will immediately own up to the idea that I may not understand issues involved with doing something like that,
But you know, if we want to improve the knowledge and the abilities of our volunteers, we want to make that as frictionless as possible.
At least I would think so,
Anyway, but it was really good to get back together with Walter and to go through and discuss what was in the guide.
I know that it will be mentioned a little later on, but kudos to Mark Ray, who authored this first volume, did a wonderful job.
Lots of very practical information, reference material and advice for scouts.
Here's the discussion that Walter and I had is going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Ten, nine, eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two, one. let's start the fun.
Today I am welcoming back to the podcast our old pal, Walter Underwood, who is in Palo Alto, California.
Walter, what in the world are you doing for scouts nowadays?
Well, I'm teaching scoutmasters and I'm approving needle projects for the district and I'm hanging out with the troop and generally having fun.
And in the past you served as a scoutmaster.
I was a scoutmaster, assistant scoutmaster, cubmaster, all kinds of things.
Okay, so the whole laundry list, huh,
Yes, I've done it.
I was even a patrol leader for just a little bit- Raccoon Patrol, a troop 26 in Beverage-
Oh, right, right down there in Louisiana.
Yeah, back in your salad days,
Back when I was wrapping hamburger meat and foil and burning it over in the coals-
Yes, a timeless tradition still carried out by the scouts of Louisiana and other environs.
I'm glad to have you back on the podcast and we're going to be talking about the first volume of the troop leader guidebook that we're both pretty thrilled with. if you want a spoiler right at the top,
I just started looking at this troop leader guidebook. You haven't seen the second volume yet, have you?
No, I haven't.
I don't think anybody has.
I haven't seen it in the editor. but, yes,
Yeah, because I don't frequent like scout shops or anything, I haven't been able to find it online anywhere,
But I'm pretty okay with this one. I think it's actually a pretty good step forward.
I like it a lot.
Yeah, I was. well, I had very high expectations when I saw that Mark Ray was writing it.
Right, yeah,
And then I was delighted when I read it.
Yeah, especially because I have kind of a collection of Scott master handbooks and most of them are not very useful.
No, they're horrible.
Yeah, well, that, yes, actually it's more accurate. Yeah, I've told Scott masters by the SPL handbook.
The Scott master handbook has the forms and stuff, but by the SPL handbook, because that tells you how to run a troop.
I have actually a first edition BSA scout master handbook.
Well, you're not missing anything.
Well, no, I got the 70s one and it's really chipper but not that useful.
I actually recycled the 1990s version. It was just didn't say anything.
No, it was pretty bad. Have you seen the new scout handbook?
You know, I've gone through it a little bit.
I think it's an improvement over the previous one. actually,
Some of the detailed stuff, like the cooking and that kind of stuff, seems okay.
It was interesting to what I grew up with actually had a page on each point of the scout law and had pictures or drawings of scouts doing things that were helpful or kind.
You're going to look at the pictures.
Yeah, the old scout handbooks, the old patrol leader handbooks, they were illustrated with cartoons.
Those are like a gateway to your imagination, because as a boy I had like the late 1940s copy of the patrol leader's handbook.
I was never involved in scouts or anything like that, but I found that handbook absolutely fascinating.
It was one of those books that was hanging around the house and I would just sit and page through it and look at those drawings. as unrealistic as some of the expectations it may set in your mind,
You know where all the fellows are rallying around the flag, waving their hats and have perfect campsites.
I thought that those drawings were more of a gateway to my imagination than the photographs that we see now.
You know there's room to put yourself into a drawing.
The photograph is just a whole different energy and I don't really understand why. but anyway.
So here we are with the troop leader guidebook.
First we just talk about utility.
Mine's set up to be put into a three ring binder.
Well, and I have a three ring binder that has a zipper and all kinds of good stuff so I can put it in there
And it's not really something I would use as a handbook or an outing.
So I think it's fine to have a bigger format.
Yeah, I think it's a good format.
I think you can put extra pages in. you can keep notes if you wanted.
It's pretty good.
I think I paid $12.99 for mine,
Something like that.
That's about right
Utility wise, as far as it being a physical object- three ring binder, that's pretty good.
The type is big enough,
Which is good for us with reading classes.
Yes, it becomes more and more important as years go by.
The only bone I have to pick with the utility of it is that it is not available in a digital version.
It's something where you need to have this available to everyone in scouting.
Well, I would have very happily paid $12.99 for a PDF version.
It's 2016,, PSA.
We really need these things in an electronic version.
Sure,
It would just make it much more mobile and a lot easier to find things
When you're trying to sort out a given subject and you have a searchable PDF.
it just makes life so much simpler.
Sure, I'm all about search.
I do.
We'll have to just live with our old fashioned paper copies.
One of the reasons that I asked you to join me and talk about this
is because you sent me an email that was very excited about this.
Tell me why
There's so much to learn as a scout master.
A lot of it is standing off and watching the boys do things,
Understanding what it is that they're supposed to do,
Making them have chances to make decisions.
It's a hard thing to do, as you know: to keep your hands in your pockets
while I try to start a fire for 45 minutes.
This really talks about that.
The other thing is that I know I expect the first place you turn to on this
is the patrol method.
I did-
How exciting is that?
What a surprise.
It's very straightforward,
Well, and it's more than one page and one paragraph.
Well, and something that I've missed in the last couple of Boy Scout Handbooks
is the one sentence that the patrol elects their leader.
Yeah, that would solve a lot of difficulties,
Partly because of parents.
Yes,
Yeah,
And this says: the patrol is a semi-permanent group of compatible scouts
who elect their own leader.
Boom,
There's no wiggle room in there.
Yeah,
And what I've learned over time is: it seems that the patrol method
is the most difficult thing to get,
And maybe in the troop that you're a member of,
somebody gave it a shot 10 years ago and didn't work out real good,
And so they decided that it wasn't really going to happen very much,
Or they were going to have a patrol method that was just so heavily
leveraged by adult influence that it really wasn't operating properly.
In this Volume 1 of the Leader Guide, Chapter 3, the patrol method-
One, two, three, four pages- is perfect.
I have no argument with anything. I've read in it.
Two things:
One, the patrol method is scary.
Oh yeah,
It's totally scary.
I mean that's why we provide a safety net,
Though no one's starved to death on a weekend camp out.
The only thing that I'm a little disappointed in is that it pushes
the new scout patrol, regular patrol version of things,
because our troop has been very successful with having mixed patrol,
mixed stage patrols.
I had new scout patrols work at other troops around here.
I wish it was a little bit more balanced, but that's
at least they do describe that mixed stage patrols are,
you know, historically the thing to do.
I was looking at this section.
There is a lot of indication that adults can be a little
more involved with all of the patrol processes than I think
is particularly wise.
I would much rather people get started with it somewhere,
learn a little bit more about it as they go along,
And this is a really good beginning.
Right,
There's probably a chapter that belongs somewhere
which is about introducing the patrol method.
Yeah,
And how do you jump into the deep end without drowning?
That's a puzzle that I know a lot of people who are
listening go through
And, in the broader idea of everything that's in this
guide, the one thing that everybody tells me-
whether they've been at this for, you know,
six months or 40 years- is that,
well, we're almost there,
We almost. we pretty much are boy led and we have
really good strong patrols and everything.
We're almost there, but that seems to be a permanent
condition.
If you're doing right that, you're never quite there.
You're almost there,
You've almost got it running.
There's the idea that somehow we're going to reach a
point where we don't have to do anything anymore
And the whole system is running on its own.
Well, and, of course, as soon as they they have it
figured out, you give them more challenges,
Right.
One of the things that's been really funny about
our troop is is seeing when I joined running with
the SPL and the senior scouts running the troop
were incredibly competent,
And then my son was running the troop.
He was not so good, but the- the parents of the
younger scouts are just like I was four years
previous and they are. I want my son to grow up to
be like that.
You know it's. it's such a process of increasing
opportunity, responsibility, all that kind of stuff.
My son is graduating from college this spring and
he just gave his senior thesis. and that is funny
when you're working with your SPL and your patrol
leaders and your your, can you call somebody
please?
You know more than the day before, more than the,
you know five o'clock for a seven pm
patrol meeting.
That's another thing that everybody talks about
as as though we're going to solve that problem.
That's never going to be solved.
No,
No, because they're figuring it out as they go
along and they're just, they just don't know
yet. and my, my son was patrol leader for a
year and a half.
The last two meetings he used the official sheet,
but he goes: wow, this really works.
Well, you know, if you stay at something long
enough, you figure it out after a while.
Everything I read in this was just kind of making
me happy.
Section three: all about youth.
I thought that was a pretty good section too.
Well, I guess it's pretty standard: BSA fair,
the ages and stages stuff.
Yeah,
This is probably the best part of the old handbook.
You have to lay that out because there's such
a difference as the Scouts grow up.
The techniques for working with youth:
I thought those were very enlightened and it
really kind of lays out what the character
of a scout master ought to be.
Right,
Because we say adult association and the
methods, but what the heck is that?
You know it's not just standing around
with a coffee cup,
Right?
And this gives you a page or two of how do
you model this, communicate it,
How do you work with youth
And how do you help them to become adults.
Following right on the tail of that,
there's sections called Teachable
Moments and Ethical Dilemmas and then,
one of my favorite things, Reflection,
And it really lays these out.
I think it lays them out pretty thoroughly
to get a grasp on them and to build them
into your repertoire as a scouter.
It's really well done,
Right.
It makes you aware of those opportunities.
The other interesting section, I thought,
or the chapter, is the one I'm working
with youth leaders,
Right?
So this is mentoring more than
the kind of one-on-one or modeling.
I'd argue with a couple of things about it,
but the thing that I especially
think everybody ought to pay attention to
is on page 74, where they talk about
setting leadership expectations.
Oh, absolutely,
Just have them write it down
Like two things:
What are you going to do?
Very simple goals,
And I hope now that adult scouts,
scoutmasters and anybody involved
with youth leaders are really thinking
very hard about what the expectations are
and having an ongoing conversation
with the scouts as they go.
That's why I like this section so much.
That's why I think this is important
for everybody to look at.
I'm delighted that the duties of a scoutmaster
are actually in the scoutmaster handbook.
Yeah, how about that?
I actually finally found them
after I was no longer a scoutmaster
in the food committee.
Just to reference that,
it's now in chapter 15..
Chapter 15, page 83..
Right,
If you look on page 83,,
first of all it starts out with scoutmaster
and it has a bulleted list of
what a scoutmaster ought to be doing,
But then it also starts talking about
assistant scoutmasters,
who actually have set responsibilities.
I might argue with some of the way
that they're set up.
What I've observed-
and I don't know if it's the same where you are-
we've had an exponential growth
of the number of people who become
volunteers and assistant scoutmasters.
If somebody's going to sign on
as an assistant scoutmaster,
there really should be a reason.
Well, yeah,
I don't care if they're a member committee
or if they're members,
Right?
The other interesting thing-
and I want to read something directly from this,
because on page 84,
over in the right-hand column,
it talks about developing a spree to core
in the scoutmaster core.
Right?
Yes,
The first bullet point reads
thusly:
Camp and eat together on troop outings.
doing so makes space
for patrols to do the same thing
and keeps adults out of the scout's way.
And make sure that you're not eating ramen
every weekend.
Yes,
I would note too
the total absence of any reference
to anything called an adult patrol.
Right,
Please, don't set up adult patrols,
Please.
Patrols are for boys.
I was looking at the parent section
and good advice.
They talk about an annual parent meeting.
We talk about a new parent conference.
On page 87,
talk about transitioning from Weebelow's leader
to an assistant scoutmaster,
which I've never seen in any official document
anywhere ever that I can recall.
Yes,
That transition
is a huge speed bump
for boys
and for adults,
for parents.
There's a section or a chapter
on working with the troop committee
about adult leader training,
Advancement and awards
has been given its own section,
having a really clear understanding
of the way advancement works.
Perhaps a little thin
on the why part here.
Yeah,
It's easy to get caught up in the ranks.
You can go to the Guide to Advancement
and there's a lot of good
why we're doing this language.
I would have liked to have seen more here.
I don't know if it's
in here.
There was a description of advancement
as a method
that said a series of
surmountable obstacles.
Right,
It's been my favorite description of that.
They're just enough
that you
could walk around them,
but you might as well go over it.
There is a section
about troop administration,
which is probably my least favorite subject
but very necessary
to understand how that works
and actually the chapters
on financing the troop
and the charter organizations, relationships,
troop communications and things
is kind of contextualized
earlier by talking about
what your relationship is with the troop committee
as a scout master.
Right,
And that's why we all love having
a wonderful committee chair,
Oh, please.
Yes,
A really good section
on health and safety guidelines
has the chart on page 118
about ages
and the different types of activities.
Who does what when?
Yeah,
Right,
The Suite 16 of BSA Safety
is like a model document
for doing safe things
anywhere with a group of people.
The next chapter includes
the safe swimming,
what it's called
Right,
Safe swim defense,
safety afloat-
Yes,
And it's all spelled out
and it's all right there,
which is great.
You know,
Trek safely is
almost too general to be useful.
I would love to have that
in a lot more detail
for different kinds of activities,
But that's probably a different book.
Well, I'll tell you where I
here's, where I fall with it.
if we were going to teach volunteers anything,
it'd be the Suite 16 of BSA Safety,
Because that basically is reiterated
in all the more specific training
such as safe swim defense,
safety afloat,
climb on safely,
trek safely
Right.
It's just more specific applications
of those 16 things.
The Suite 16 has always made
a whole lot of sense to me
and it's been very useful.
The whole age guidelines
for tool use
and works at elevations
or excavations,
which is one of.
for some reason,
this just seems to be one of the ones
that is a perennial question mark
in a lot of people's minds
And it just engenders
a lot of conversation
and disagreement.
Well, now, here it is.
It's right here
And it's been on the
national website for years.
I've been giving it out
to Eagle Scout candidates
for their projects for years,
But I'm glad to see it here.
Yes,
Everyone knows it exists.
My favorite is the paint roller
on extension pole.
I just have a picture of an
11-year-old with one of these things-
An 11-year-old and a paint roller
On an extension pole-
Extension pole or no,
An 11-year-old and a paint roller.
there should be one of those
international no signs right there.
Go watch an hour of
the Three Stooges.
Yes,
Especially the part where they're holding
the ladder on his shoulder
and keep turning around.
Yeah,
Because that's what you're going to see
if you do that.
I didn't see anything
new in the Youth Protection
chapter,
Right,
And the BSA has been a model
for youth protection.
Yeah,
They used that at the World Jamboree
last time.
Yeah,
The BSA was the model
for the World Program.
Yeah,
Just keep it up.
And then the next chapter
is Chapter 27,.
the infamous height-weight
limits for activities
and the chart-
Yep,
Something that causes a whole
lot of consternation
and discussion anymore.
It's right here at your fingertips,
Mr Stumpmaster.
Yeah,
So the appendix
actually is available online
as a PDF.
Yeah, that's handy.
All those checklists
and forms and all that good stuff.
you don't have to go.
they're actually available,
Right,
It is nice to have the
annual planning conference stuff
pulled into this book.
Mm-hmm,
Because it used to be
as I found it
much, much later
after I was a scout master.
it used to be
the introduction
to troop program
features or whatever
in Volume 1..
And it was tucked away in there
with great explanation
about exactly how to do
an annual planning conference-
Mm-hmm-
Which you didn't ever see
unless you actually read that book.
So now everybody's on it
seeing it.
So now you can do annual planning.
You know this is an example-
with the tool use guidelines,
annual planning,
height and weight guidelines,
all those kind of stuff
that's been pulled into one place
for the scout master.
A very good combination of
explanations of the why of the program,
along with really good reference information
finally been put in one place.
When I was teaching
introduction to outdoor leader skills in March,
I told everybody:
just go buy this,
Just get it.
Yeah,
You know
you've already been through
it, but go get this,
You're going to find something useful.
Anybody- just the first few pages,
is probably going to learn something new.
Yes,
It's just really well done.
And we wait with beta breath
for Volume 2..
So we'll see how that goes,
Walter, I guess when we get
to the end of this
and we're looking at it,
I'm definitely a thumbs up on this one.
It's two thumbs up from us.
Yeah,
Yes,
I mean, I've been for years.
I've been recommending that
scout masters get the SPL handbook,
And I still do.
Yeah,
That's actually a great idea,
by the way. everybody
But this one,
this one would bore the snot out of SPLs,
but it's got tons of great information
for scout masters.
Yeah,
And very practically put together
and well worth doing.
Good job, Mark Ray.
Yes,
One of those claps
is that we do it. campfires, right,
Right.
Round of applause.
A round of applause for Mark Ray.
Thank you, Mark.
It's good to have you back
on the podcast. Walter,
Glad to talk to you again.
Well, thanks so much
for listening to this
313th edition
of the Scout Master Podcast.
I'd love to hear from you.
I'd like to hear your thoughts,
ideas, questions and comments.
You can get in touch with me
in several different ways.
You can join the ever burgeoning
throng of folks who follow us
in the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
We have over 13,000 folks
follow us on Facebook.
We have a large and growing
chorus of tweeters on Twitter.
We have a couple of
thousand folks who peruse
the pultritudinous pictures we
print publicly on Pinterest,
And we've got videos
over on YouTube,
so make sure to check all that out.
But look, if you can't face Facebook
and Twitter makes you better
and you've no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube.
if you're just an old grump
like me,
well, zoom in to the late 90s
and send off a good old-fashioned
email.
You can get in touch with me
at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom,
at C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, if none of those
ways work for you,
grab a blanket, a pack of matches,
head to a nearby hill or mountain
or geographical prominence
in your area,
Kindle a mid-size smoky fire
and use the blanket, as
in days of old, to differentiate
between different puffs of smoke.
Send up three puffs,
Wait a minute,
Send up three more.
Before too long, across the valley
you'll see another moderately
sized smoky fire kindle
and I will answer all of your questions
Now. by this time,
it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcaster
are not official publications
of anyone in particular,
including the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization,
And what I do is not
endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization.
Nope, it's just me.
I'm a volunteer
like everybody else, okay,
And I'm just trying to do my best
to help my fellow scouters out
and have a little bit of fun
along the way.
And speaking of fun,
here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.
Good luck to you
and good camping.